hi everyone i'm kevin i work on
uh business development here at wolf
from um the eureka program
is a new program that we just started a
few months ago the goal of the program
is where we're hoping to help guide and
guide aspiring entrepreneurs as they
launch or build their startup and we're
hoping to foster networking within the
group as well
so uh we'll be hosting one or two events
a month
and members of eureka will be able to
attend those events we've already held i
think it's
three really successful events so far
and where we have a lot more planned
if you're interested in applying for
eureka i think the the link is
unpassable
um so today we're really excited to be
holding our fourth event at uh wtc
and opening it up today uh to the wtc
crowd
um we want to make sure that we're
designing and holding events that are
impactful so if you have a chance at the
end
please leave us some feedback on
passable we'll also have time at the end
for q a
so feel free to leave your questions in
the chat and i'll
you know keep track of them throughout
the event so that let me pass it over to
john
great thanks kevin i'm john woodard um
so here we have our inaugural kind of
event
where we're interviewing the founder and
we're really excited
and happy to have uh phil meyman
and the the name of this segment we're
calling it my eureka moment
as you'll see like we have a signature
question around that um
phil is a co-founder and cto of swipe
dot
bet a tinder for sports betting offering
you live in-game bets
things you will like and allowing you to
swipe right to accept or left to pass
i'd actually encourage you if you can to
go to swipe.bet there's actually a
mailing list if you're interested
in kind of learning more as that story
progresses i just first wanted to just
start with the basics
phil um tell us a little bit about
yourself your professional background
interests and how you kind of got into
things
uh my background is i used to be a hedge
fund manager that was my first job
out of college uh so i was a trader at
uh long term capital in ellington
management group and then my own hedge
fund we had with my dad
um where we traded behavioral relative
value and stuff
uh then i went into academia i went to
get my phd
and after that you know you get your phd
you have to
you have to either go directly to become
a professor or kind of never
because because if you wait a couple
years and then you try to
become a professor like why haven't you
published well i haven't published i've
been working you know it's like
proprietary
and stuff so i forgot to give it a shot
and that's been fun um
sorry am i having some feedback oh just
there how's that better
when you so we started looking the
sports analytics evolved right about 10
years ago
it like broke out of nowhere where
suddenly it was like everywhere um
and me and my brother and a friend of
ours uh close friend we started
writing some papers on trying to take
the tools and techniques of finance and
apply it to
sports analytics uh and since then my
you know i started off as a professor of
finance and risk engineering at nyu
then i went to another place bridgeport
and there was finance and analytics now
i'm at
fairfield where i'm just analytics i
don't do finance anymore just
pure data now so that's that's me that's
where i've been at
gotcha so i have a bunch of follow-up
questions here
because you've had like so many exciting
experiences i think
as you've developed so one long-term
capital management
please tell us more about your
experiences there
and kind of what it was like at the end
what what a wonderful place to work
wonderful people and it was a couple
years ago was the 20-year anniversary
of uh 1998 it's crazy uh so many people
may not have heard even of long-term
capital management yes
it was the best hedge fund uh ever at
the time in 1998 we had two nobel
laureates
as uh daily active working partners uh
nobel laureates in
economics one of them is myron scholes
the others bob merton they both
created along with fisher black the
options pricing yes like the
thing the thing and they were the guys
and they were with us and
it was the uh i learned a lot from them
not just about finance but about
business and life because
when you start a company the culture is
really important they had such a flat
structure everybody could approach
everybody uh
you know you have discussions with with
myron shows or bob merton or john
merryweather like and just it's just
chatting it's amazing um
and and they made everybody feel welcome
and valued uh so it was a great place to
work and then 1998 happened and what
happened in 1998 was
russia defaulted on its domestic debt
there was a flight to quality it was
kind of a wholesale
uh problem rather than a retail problem
the stock market didn't move much but
a lot of the spreads blew out and um at
the time
it's hard to imagine this is 1998
there's like hardly any internet
so we'd be right checking emails in
bloomberg every morning i was in tokyo
during the the the incident um so
we were fine but we'd be checking every
morning to see has warren buffett bought
us yet or not
so it's good yeah that's amazing because
for me it's like
um i took the course i took in finance
in college was with um
the guy at yale i forgot his name it's
embarrassing because i'm trying to
actually humble brag
nick barbarus maybe he just won a nobel
in economics oh oh
uh uh i can't think of the name but but
anyway so
he he would talk about hedge funds and
robert schiller is a guy's name
oh of course yeah right yeah yeah um but
so he would talk about hedge funds and
everything else
but i remember reading about long-term
capital management in the new yorker
like this is just pre pre-internet it's
hard to like think about the
time and everything um but tell us too
about like
being at nyu in finance i know there's
someone famous there as well
um what was that like oh that was
awesome
that was a great department uh so nassim
taleb also an innovator award winner
wolfram user mathematica extraordinaire
uh he was there we had great chats it
was a nice environment because it was
very
it wasn't the theoretical ivory tower
kind of stuff that finance can sometimes
devolve into is very practical and
hands-on
uh real-world kind of uh kind of stuff
both with the derivatives valuations but
also kind of anything uh
even behavioral finance algorithmic
finance um it was uh it was a hot bit of
really interesting risk and risk
engineering activity
gotcha yeah and and i think you also
talked about like your experiences
with sports analytics and this to me is
like amazing because
there's all of these you know programs
and movies and
pop culture now with moneyball and all
these things but it's like you're on the
forefront of that too so like
tell me about the uh the mit sloan
conference
and what you kind of did there and maybe
some of your experiences with that
sure so they started uh about 10 years
ago having a research paper track
the sloan sports analytics conference is
the largest sports analytics maybe one
of the largest conferences in the world
it has
3 000 people to send on to the
convention center in boston
and you know you're walking around the
halls and there's all these tall
people some of them are gms some of them
are players you know from the nba
uh and most of the most of the
conference
is these wonderful panels where it's
like a thousand people in the room and
they're discussing
uh what's the what's about what's
happening in the future of basketball or
what's
uh esports or or sports betting
um with questions from the audience and
twitter and everything barack obama
spoke a couple years ago
um so it's a it's a huge event and about
eight ten years ago something like that
they added a track
the research papers track where people
would submit uh
analytical research about the sport of
their choice or a variety of sports
um and so we started submitting to that
and going and it's just so wonderful
so it's really hard to find a sports
analytics
event or venue where hundreds of people
show up and you're like walking them
through you know machine learning or
regressions or something you know
so it's a really wonderful experience
it's it's it's something
if if you're interested in sports index
it's definitely good to go they have a
lot of additional helpful things like uh
career placement and advice and uh a
hackathon and lots of other great things
so one of the things that that interests
me about like the sports analytics is
this comparison of taking like
um financial kind of models and forgive
me for like my lack of experience with
finance but like
the the financial sort of models and
taking that and trying to to look at
like
real world kind of things that coaches
do and i think you have a story about
that and i'd really love to hear it too
yeah that was the first paper we wrote
with uh my brother alan and our friend
eugene shen
we uh we thought what's the easiest
thing to prove that everyone's an idiot
in basketball right
and we thought well this is clearly easy
early foul trouble
you watch it all the time a great player
gets two
fouls called on him in the first quarter
and you get in basketball you get up to
six fouls then you're disqualified
you can't play the rest of the game but
very rarely does anybody ever foul out
uh people just start playing less
aggressively less more more
conservatively um but in any case when
you get two early fouls let's say the
first five six minutes you can watch any
basketball game as soon as this happens
the coach yanks them almost immediately
because they want to keep them for later
parts of the game so we thought this is
ridiculous
this is ridiculous because they never
foul out
so you're getting less minutes played by
your best players
right just play them just play them the
points a first quarter point is worth
the same as a fourth quarter point at
the point is a point
you want to maximize the minutes played
if he fouls out he fouls out once in a
while no big deal
so we thought this would be really easy
to prove so we ran like you said the
financial techniques the
simulations the everything and it turns
out we were wrong
the coaches were right all along but it
was mind-blowing uh like there was there
were subtleties like
we had some things to suggest but
basically uh there are lots of times
when it does make sense
to pull your star and keep them and it's
because of optionality convexity it's
the fact that
they can come back and play during a
an important clutch fourth quarter when
it's really close game
that optionality can outweigh their
additional drift or the additional
amount of
points they can earn for you early does
that make sense yeah
yes i mean it's it's it's just amazing
to me
um and it seems like these sort of
things kind of compounded in a way
to like your experience in startups
and doing stuff with sports and with
with gaming
um so this kind of leads up to our
signature moment if we had live sound
effects would be kind of cool about it
what was your eureka moment um
with swipe.bet or in my life well
well i guess we can we can go through
like several of them so we can go
through like
maybe your life is most important but
then also we could talk about
um i think there's a couple of moments
with swipe.bet as well
um so let's start with your life and
then go to swipe.bet let's start with
the important stuff first well i don't
know about my life i can tell you
uh with mathematica i when we were
running our hedge fund with me and my
dad he had written some early stuff i
don't know 20 years ago
in mathematica uh like a credit default
curt fault swap price was the first in
the world so he he knew about the power
and he introduced me to it i remember
reading
the mathematica book i think it was for
version four or five and so i learned it
and it was fun
but then what blew my mind this was my
first eureka moment ever
with uh with computers i think
programming was manipulate
were you alive when manipulate came i
mean version six that was
mind-blowing right mind-blowing all the
dynamic functionality now we take it all
for granted it's you know sliders big
deal
but it was uh it was a major shift in in
my head like that it took me a while to
really understand what was going on
and how that was that could be possible
um
with swipe.bet our first so
i co-founded it with my with my partner
brett mcdonald and we had worked at a
previous
uh company together called vantage
sports i found vantage because i was
doing sports analytics i was consulting
for nba teams and stuff
and what had happened in the nba
recently was optical tracking data so
this
six cameras on top of every arena on all
29 arenas looking down and capturing the
center of mass
25 frames per second of all 10 players
and the three referees and the x y and z
location of the ball
so you can see how high it was it was
incredible so it was a revolution in
sports athletics which people don't
understand but it's been happening
people who think of sports analytics
like moneyball kind of stuff they think
of regressions
right and kind of that kind of you know
let's just we there's a fight between
the
scouts and the the nerds or geeks or
whatever right
that's long gone like that that that war
has been fought that's over right
like yes you have to do analytics um but
the
regression stuff doesn't work very well
once you have these
millions and billions of rows of
location data the tools that you need
are more
computational and artificial
intelligence machine learning all the
stuff so that was the transition that
was happening and we found that one of
the things that even with all the
machine learning and even with all this
data what was still missing
in basketball you know we all play
basketball
what is the most important thing if
you're taking a shot what's the worst
thing that can happen to you what do you
want to know on defense
what we can measure is how close the
person was to you who that person was
the shock like we know all that
but what we don't know there's no data
not in any box or not nowhere else
to tell you if the defender's hand was
up right and you know if the guy is
putting his hands down
easy shot right come on but so things
like that or whether us
a pick was being set solidly or not or
the guy was cutting to the basket and
looking for a pass
even if it didn't come all these things
that the human eye can see
very very easily but computers could not
so we had a company that we had 50
people
full-time jobs was looking at these
games was it a crossover left to right
did he go behind his back did he pass
every single thing an incredible amount
of information uh
and the first eureka thought there was
okay what's our next sport that we're
gonna do after basketball we were
thinking soccer maybe
um but esports came out to be huge uh
and uh i had never heard of esports at
that point and now i'm addicted to them
um esports are you know
they're sports but it's just people
pressing buttons on a computer uh
and people in madison square garden all
these arenas sell out
where people pack it they buy the hot
dogs in the pocket they're literally
just watching five people on computers
over here and five people on computers
over there
uh so that was the first one as we
realized there's something there the
next one
we started the basketball stuff it was a
unique form of data so we started
selling it to gamblers
and they started using it to make uh
additional money so that was good so we
realized there's something
in the gambling market when uh gambling
became essentially legalized
uh a year or so ago uh in america we
thought
what what's going to happen what what
would be a useful
way to participate in this market
because there's lots of sports books
there's lots of casinos there's lots of
other ways of doing it but they're all
kind of dirty and shady and
you have to learn this ridiculous lingo
of odds and
whatever yes yes
definitely i mean i i definitely know
there because it's like i think i was
telling you before it's like i learned
all the sports betting lingo from casino
and other you know las vegas movies in
terms of like
how would i even approach this and it
definitely like means that
it just seems unapproachable where there
are things like i would spend money
for entertainment wise because i kind of
understand them
so yeah and all of that is not done for
the benefit of the better obviously it's
done for the benefit of the sports book
because those things are easier to
to hedge and to trade and to manage the
risk on
um it's really hard to offer a bet on
something like
will lebron james score five points in
the next eight minutes right that's a
hard
bet to offer because if you just offer
it to the world
somebody who knows that he was injured
or knows that his opponent was injured
can just lay down a huge amount of money
and boom you're out of business right
and you're offering those thousands of
times all the time
but we thought that's the way to go
that's what people want right
all the the fact that gambling is now
legal people
want to bet on meaningful in-game action
right
and they push sportsbook please let me
bet on live action
and the sport's like here have have a
little you can bet on like halftime
scores or something and then now look at
all our other offerings please
upsell over here but if we could focus
on that area that was the first
that was not quite a eureka because we
we knew that was the opportunity
right we'd like to offer that something
simple now tinder was really hot at the
time but i think it's still hard people
know
easy you know swipe right if you like
something swipe left
if you don't we thought what if we could
do that with bets that was the first
thought to make things easy for people
to bet but then
here comes the eureka moment and i'm
happy to share this with you now because
we just got a patent on it so i can tell
you
i will have questions about that too all
the details
uh the idea is this we're going to offer
you we want to make it as simple as
possible so first of all
no odds every bet that we're offering to
you is you either make you pick a bet
size initially say 10 bucks 100 bucks a
bet
you either win a hundred bucks or lose a
hundred bucks there's no vig or commish
or anyone to break your kneecaps or
anything and you're not even betting
against
us this was the beautiful part in every
sports book no matter how
friendly their stock images are they're
royalty free stock images on the website
you're ultimately betting against the
person that you're doing business with
but with us no you're actually not
betting against us and our secret is
this
we're going to offer you curated bets
just like tinder
we're not going to say here's a
wide-open delhi style menu pick what you
want throw in money
no we we know who you are we've looked
deep into your soul and we also know
your past
betting experience and preferences we
think you would really like
this live bet lebron we think you like
betting on the bronze scoring five
points the next eight minutes if you
continuously swipe left on those kind of
operas we'll eventually learn okay you
don't like lebron bets fine we'll offer
you
steph curry bets whatever you want um so
you
you're getting a curated you get a deck
of cards uh
live we pick it out at the time this is
also cute
uh when do you offer these bets you
can't offer them like during a fast
break
right because everything can change uh
so we find moments in every game
that are lulls how do you find a lull in
a game
if you've all seen like wind probability
graphs like here's how the game is
moving here's the wind probability how
it changes over time
so we look at that we have models of
wind probability and we look
for when the volatility of the wind
probability
is low meaning it's not changing much if
the wind probability is
relatively stable that means what's
happening now is irrelevant
maybe it's a time out maybe it's a free
throw being shot maybe it's someone
arguing with the ref who knows
but it's a it could be near zero could
be near one or anywhere between but it's
a lull
at that moment we'll start offering you
bets and you'll start getting dings on
your phone oh look that's a nice bet
because
this is the time when you'll be looking
away from the on court product anyway
right
and rather than going somewhere else
this is a way to keep you engaged
so this is good for the sports teams
it's good for the leagues it's good for
tv um you we offer you some bets you
swipe right or left
and here here's the thing because we're
offering it as curated
we can automatically balance the book so
you're not trading against us you're
trading against other people
right i mean that that to me is just
amazing because it's almost like
just like finance and sports
and like the engagement for
the um the folks who are out there like
watching i mean you're hitting them
right at the moment where
as you said they're like potentially
looking away or maybe they're multiple
games going on
and they might you know have several tvs
or do whatever
like move through different things so
it's like perfect because you're getting
them involved in like
a small like slice
of the game of that moment where you
said like oh the next five minutes or
the next two minutes
where now that's like a game in and of
itself to pay attention to
and watch and root for and that to me is
amazing well
that's that's really well put that's
exactly what it is and you and
everybody's getting it at the same time
so if you're playing with your friends
you can compete on roughly the same kind
of opportunities and you can see who bet
better right right right oh absolutely i
didn't even think about that but like
that kind of um highlights that that
competitive nature that people would
have too and make it exciting
for people um who aren't like with you
at the moment
but are kind of playing with you like or
watching along with you too it like
makes that more interactive
it's just really amazing i'm i'm like
when you first told me about it i was
just like oh this is such a great idea
um so another thing with this is like
you talked about the patent process and
going through that
like what was that like in terms of
getting a technology
patent it was terrifying for me because
it was my first one
and i kept worrying that because at the
same time we're raising capital we're
talking to potential partners
so you know i didn't really want to tell
them too much because what if we don't
get the patent you know
then they could come in and compete with
us or whatever but thank god we got it
my partner brett he uh he never worried
about it not for a second he would
always calm me down
part of the reason is he's he has a
background in patent law so good for him
uh but he's done that right have a good
one so we filed a provisional patent
then it just got approved we're very
excited
um and it got approved completely like
just 100 percent everything we
uh we put in there uh so it's really
innovative it's
we're really happy about that um now i'm
no longer terrified so
yeah i said well congratulations two
times one for like getting it and then
also for like taking that down because i
i kind of know like i think we lots of
entrepreneurs kind of know that like you
have this eureka moment
you're working on things and then you're
like oh my gosh can i even protect this
from like the the rabid like kind of um
close followers that may even get more
advantage for like
following like your hard work and idea
and everything else
um so that's that's that's really
congratulations on that
thank you and the patent if you've seen
patent law
language it's so formal and weird it
looks like english but it has these like
weird phrases such as therefore the
above right if you don't put them in
like you're screwed
so you really need a good patent lawyer
it might be a fun application for
wolfram language to try to parse it
right and put it into a tree form
because it's all very rigid
yeah but but you know flowery english
language
yes yes keeps lots of like patent agents
lawyers
patent examiners yes all like well
employed
um so going back to like swipe.bet and
kind of those
those goals that you might have what are
kind of your short term maybe six months
to a year
goals so the biggest hurdle which we now
have
cleared is we we don't have a sports
gambling right license right you have to
go state by state a jurisdiction by
jurisdiction
and you have to geofence the app so that
even if you're legal in new jersey and
it's a new jersey resident but if
they're not in new jersey at the time
they're placing the bet
you know call the cops so we've we've
partnered with somebody who has the
licenses
um and we're so we're very excited about
that we're gonna start launching
games the nice thing is because it's all
built on uh wolf languages it's very
flexible we can add a new game in like a
week or two
a brand new sport we've done it before
we've done it for for football for
basketball for soccer
um i think one more at baseball so
adding a new one takes only a week or
two
uh so we're gonna probably start with uh
hockey or or
uh esports um and we're gonna go that's
the short-term goal is to get those live
as soon as possible
gotcha gotcha and so you've talked about
like the
the geo fencing i guess that's involved
in that and like
and those sorts of things um
i guess we talked about in terms of
challenges you had
the the patent law kind of challenges
were there other kind of challenges that
came up that the patent law the
um working with the the sports gambling
kind of licensure and other stuff
what other sort of challenges did you
initially
kind of have explaining this idea
is people react the way you react like
normal people
understand that this is something they
want to use but when you approach a
casino or a sports book they just think
well i don't care about risk
we've literally had people tell us i
don't care about that risk i can manage
that i don't
whatever i don't i don't need to worry
about balancing the book
uh so you know there's probably a blow
up coming soon
right if they really don't care right um
yeah because i mean i think for me from
a gaming perspective
um i think i've told everybody at wolf
from this at least
a couple of times and i'm gonna go into
i don't have it open i i would like open
it up and show people
but i have i'm level 40 in
pokemon go and what that helped me to
realize because initially i was like
i don't understand why people even like
this why would you like pokemon all i
understand is pikachu but now i like
know all these pokemon and everything
um and i've spent an embarrassing amount
of money
on pokemon go as a an
application that i can tune into and
play mindlessly
or like walk around in different cities
like when i was in uh hong kong
macau like all these places they have
special regional pokemon
that you grab them but it's kind of like
that um but the interesting thing for me
is that i realize that lots of people
love games and they want to participate
in games and they will spend money
if they understand what they're doing so
i don't understand this disconnect
of like the casino operators or the
gambling operators or
fantasy sports or even like the
television networks
of not not quite getting getting that
but
yeah it's it's a it's a combination so
what what i think is driving it is
people want to bet on real live in-game
action
right and all these other things are
proxies so the sports bets and the
casinos they
they found a proxy that works over under
his lines whatever
fantasy has found us a different proxy
that works we have to have a portfolio
so you're not just betting on one player
none of them get to exactly what people
want to bet out we're trying to offer
them exactly what they want
but they're all kind of proxies um for
for esports so in pokemon now that
you're level 40.
do you still play or are you retired
it's a difficult question i mean they
try to intrigue me with
new um different like they have like
these mega
pokemon now and i'll play and like
they've added new features to like
new network features so you can interact
with your friends and play all these
things that you kind of mentioned
with swipe.bet in terms of trying to do
that but it gets
like your attention level i think
um decays and there's nothing that they
can really do to get you
back like really active and get your
pocketbook kind of open again
because it's just like once things
happen it happens but that's why i see
like with sports as a game and an app
you guys have lots of ways to get me
like back
into picking up the app again and
looking at it
um yeah i think if there's we should
chat maybe there's a way to do it for
pokemon if there's some way to bet that
you would find a particular pokemon the
next few minutes or something right that
might be a useful application
yeah i mean i think that there are ways
that they can do it because they have
coins in-game now you cannot
kind of take your coins
and give them to somebody else or like
trade
items but i think it's getting there
because like you battle
with people and it would certainly be
more interesting to battle with people
if like you lost a pokemon or they could
use one of your pokemon like marbles
like my dad like my dad had this story
like
quite a bit ago um where he was not
allowed to play marbles because he grew
up
um in a very religious household because
it was gambling because
you know you lose the marbles by you
know oh my god when you when you play
and you're actually playing the marble
game
you're actually betting because they
think oh my gosh
um that's crazy so yeah um
so in esports the way just so people
understand the way the
it's it's completely different from
other sports the way money is made uh
in let's say basketball or football or
anything else um
the the league makes money basically
from selling the live airtime right to
espn or disney or abc
in esports it's a free game like say
league of legends
it's been around for 10 years it's
completely free to play you there's no
way to pay money to improve your
character or your abilities or anything
else
everybody is literally on the exact same
playing field the only thing
they sell are little skins or chromas
that so your character
looks a little different behaves
completely the same but looks a little
bit different
and maybe one or two percent of users
ever spent a nickel
on these games right but just from those
one or two percent they make billions of
dollars
wow just from people buying all these
skins and with esports i know that this
was something
um that um when we talked previously
about that
it seems like so complex and that
they're rising and falling
how do you feel like you guys are going
to to keep up and like
do and integrate things in in that kind
of
in that kind of environment that's a
great question because it's something
that every sports book would be worried
about right how do you offer a bet in a
game that might be gone in a year or two
but for us as i was saying with wolfram
it's so flexible we can add it or
change a game almost instantly so as
rules change especially in esports they
have tweaks and patches every week or
two
if there's a new champion if there's a
new kind of abilities things other
things that people can bet on
uh boom we can integrate it basically
overnight the next day
you have a new bet on a new champion or
a new map or whatever else is happening
so one of the other questions like you
talked about having like
the patent and having like some of these
issues that people might have
what has like the fundraising process
been like like how did you get your
initial
kind of fundraising how do things look
like for the next
year or so in terms of in terms of that
process for you so what my partner brett
mcdonald he uh
he's great at this he's been in the
startup business for he's one of the
most entrepreneurial people i know on
earth
um and he has a lot of contacts and he's
he pitches them so
we've had some angels and stuff we've
applied to a few
uh startup incubators um i think we even
made it yeah we made it to a final round
but then they ended up not investing
with us
but that was before we got the patent
and now we probably don't need them
anymore
what would have been useful about the
incubators would be their
network of relationships uh that they
can introduce us to
a warm introduction to a sports book or
casino goes a lot longer than
you know a message on linkedin hey you
guys like gambling well check this out
right
that's like that's like something you
get every day on linkedin actually right
um no that's that's really fascinating
so
and i think from what you said just as
kind of a little bit of a recap
um because of your model of kind of
balancing
it's like now you just seem like you
need to raise money
to expand your technology and to scale
right um
as opposed to kind of backing um
the different bets which you know is
phenomenal right um
but how do you anticipate being able to
grow
like how are you how will you get users
we have two models where
we're working on simultaneously one is
b2c and one is b2b with direct to
consumer
um that's a harder road
uh if we were to go it completely alone
but fortunately we've partnered with a
company now that has a gaming license so
we can go out and uh market and find
people and
engage them and sign them up just like
any other business just starting up
the nice thing also is we don't have
very high network effects we don't need
that many people to sign up
it's not like we need a facebook or
something right every little marginal
uh sign up gets immediate value uh to
themselves and to us and to everybody
else
so that's number one uh we also
have uh
b to b so b to b the way it would work
is we would offer to license our
technology to a sports book or casino
where they would white label it they
would offer it for themselves and it
could be even to a media company we
could do it for fake money or for real
money if they're
tnt or espn or anyone else is
broadcasting the game then they want to
say hey
during a commercial break you don't want
people to go away right so you say hey
what do you think will happen in the
next five minutes go to this app click
and whether it's fake money or real
money or t-shirts or whatever it is
it keeps people engaged so if we white
label it it doesn't even have to have
swipe.bet on it
they'll just say their name we'll just
power the technology behind it
um that approach where we've been
working on
but it's it's b2c you want
lots and lots of little teeny tiny deals
right b to b you want just a handful of
really big deals um so once
one of those big deals happen then
there's questions of exclusivity versus
non-exclusivity
um we we we're approaching both
we think either one can be viable
gotcha gotcha um and then like i think
we want to
close out my kind of part of things and
like go to
to questions in the audience i did have
one more
question that that i wanted to ask um
and it's just in general like
you notice we or people may notice that
we are all
at home or or in offices like
not not as much around um because
there's this pandemic that's out there
how do you
feel like that what pandemic i know
right
um how do you feel like that's affecting
um the landscape of kind of
your business and um
the people who will will um
use your your app out there uh it's
beneficial to us in a couple of ways one
is uh
sports have been kind of stopped playing
tell me come say hi uh
so when they do start up um uh
there's more attention on them uh the
other nice thing and they can change
quickly with rule changes so again we
can uh quickly adapt to them
the second nice thing is like you
mentioned this earlier you know you have
buddies
but you can't really hang out with them
all the time right especially because of
this
forsaken pandemic but if you can watch a
game together and you know that has to
be live you can't watch a game on
record right you're not all going to
sync it up exactly cause you're all
watching it live and you can also start
betting with each other so it's a give
it's a way of connecting
across the ether right even across time
zones and maybe you don't even have them
on the phone but you know you have you
have a feeling
you can see how they're doing it
compared to you and vice versa it's a
pleasant experience
yeah absolutely i think that's the thing
it ties it ties people together and it's
something that
like i know from again like my pokemon
experience i invite everybody out there
to
not only play pokemon um but also play
other games just so you can get an
idea of like you'll find a game for you
you may not
you may think other people's games are
like silly and whatever but
you'll probably find some game for you
and if you're in
um kind of the startup frame of mind
you'll see
like why it's going to be i think this
growing area where people are able to
connect and do things together
um so with that i think i will hand over
more to the audience and i think kevin
will will have questions
from the audience for phil yeah um
if you if you have any questions please
feel free to drop them in a chat and
uh i'll take a look at that through that
um so first phil
um how how and why why
have you used uh wolf language and swept
out that
oh we use it for the back end so the
front end app we
built so the back end we built we have a
running server and it's been beautiful
and consistent and stable and remarkably
good for everything that we run in the
background all of the bet matching and
sending stuff out um uh so it runs on
the server
uh and it powers the the entire back end
of the app
the front end um we had we used uh we
used this
new programming language called flutter
which is cross-platform you can make an
android and
ios app but speaking of which for
entrepreneurs out there who
know wolfram language and here you are
right these are the right people
uh that i think there's an opportunity
to make some kind of cross-platform
wolfram language enabled
app maker right because the there's only
so many different components in an app
a good thing to look into is like
jasonette you know there's there's date
pickers or
or labels or images or embedded html and
all these other things
if you just write each of those and you
can also connect to a wolfram engine
running locally now because the iphones
are more powerful than the space shuttle
was when it launched right up right
so if you can have the engine running
locally you imagine all the power of
wolfram language on any app
right and it's cross-platform you only
have to write the cross-platform part
once uh anyway i think that would be
awesome i would love to have a front-end
that we built
in wolfram as well i have a question
from john if you're back in
geo redundant yes
i'm actually not sure what that means
what does that mean
maybe i don't know what it means we have
like failovers right so if one goes down
then we can
then another one will take its place i
see
but john if that's not what you meant
let me know
hot remote standby yes um
and speaking of aspiring entrepreneurs
if you could offer one piece of advice
to an aspiring entrepreneur what would
you say
um usable from language and i'll tell
you why
because uh it's it's not just it's not
just a cliche um
john we've talked about this we've both
seen companies
that have raised five ten or more
million dollars
in vc funding that are literally
a one-liner in mathematics in wolf
language
so you know it's there's work to be done
there i don't know how they raise the
money but
so you have to have a sales team you
have to work at it it's business it's
not just you write a one line and sit
back and relax i wish it was that easy
but if you write the one-liner right and
then you can also tweak it and so much
easier
because all like that um uh
then you go out and market it and just
know that i think the biggest hurdle to
overcome is
just the fact that you are able to write
something useful in a very very short
concise amount of time and it's when
it's working
doesn't mean that it's not valuable all
right like stephen
wilfred says uh the the entire our
entire universe might be a one-liner
right and that's not nothing so right if
your idea is a one-liner
it's good right and i know exactly the
company that you're
talking about they will really remain
nameless
to protect the guilty or presume well i
will presume them to be innocent i
suppose
no they're in i'm sure they built it off
their ground up they did a good job
yeah yeah it's just funny that yeah
um john brings up another good question
um upon success right it
you know um uh can you hire backend
engineers or are you
are you will you train them in-house
what is your plan for kind of hiring
talent i would uh i would probably look
to hire
people who attend the world from tech
conference because those are the people
who would know how to run
back end will for language code um and
then obviously not everyone knows
everything right wolf language is
impossible for any human being to know
but then we train them and then it's
just like any other work
and just just like a plug-in like that
that's that's part of the point of like
eureka
is you know we have a lot of people who
are interested in um
well from technology who know how to use
our technology and we gathered and all
the ones who are interested in
entrepreneurship in one spot and that
makes you know hiring easier that makes
um kind of pitching your ideas and
talking about your ideas easier because
these are all
you know this is like your group of
people that you want to talk to right
that you want to hire
right um so yeah that's part of the and
again if you're interested
in joining eureka there's a link to that
impossible
yeah and i think it's such a wonderful
thing you're doing uh it's it's
wonderful for wolfram
because you want to have a portfolio of
options right rather than an option on a
portfolio
and it's really useful for the startups
right because
it's i i can imagine there's two groups
of people that are interested one is
people who can write really good will
from code or or have some ability to
write some will from code right they
don't have to be the best in anything in
the world but they have
they can express their thoughts in the
wolfram language which is the only
computational language on earth that's
one
but then you also have business people
who are interested in tech and
and software and everything and they are
familiar with wolfram language
but maybe they're not as experts but
they have additional skills
i think a lot of the skill of a business
is something like what my partner brett
does is
you know the soft side the selling the
meeting people the networking right
that has to happen no matter how good
your code is we still are
we're still human beings right well
again
i'm going to plug for swipe.bet
you can actually go to the site i think
there's a demo and there's definitely a
mailing list so you can kind of follow
phil on on the journey there um
speaking of that i know that there's
another uh question
in a way um how did you test your app
initially because it seemed like this
area where you
might have to like have like something
different
to test yeah because the problem was the
yeah real money you know we can't
we couldn't do real money we needed we
had to have some kind of demo that's
using fake money
what can we use that's constantly
playing what kind of sport is always on
well we did we settled on finance and we
had a toy little test app of uh
15-minute delayed yahoo finance prices
um actually i think we we probably just
used directly financial data if i
remember right
um so it's 50 minutes delayed life
prices and the bets
the bets that would come to your cards
would be do you think microsoft will be
up more than one percent in the next
five minutes or something right yes no
yes no and then you track it live too so
you see how you're doing on
on all of your bets uh that's fun to
play it's obviously not
you know you can't it's 50 minutes delay
so you just find the real price
so
i guess here's ah
there's a bunch of questions in chat
let's see
todd is asking have you encountered any
limitations in the wolfram language that
will from the company
have helped you overcome um
almost daily there's a
many times uh nothing immediate comes to
mind because it just feels like a
natural thing that happens all the time
whether it's on stack exchange and
or wolfram community where uh the or you
send in a support ticket and you get a
response within like a day or two
from the person who wrote the code you
know
like that's pretty cool and they'll
either tell you a workaround and
sometimes there are lots of easy
workarounds that are just either
undocumented or unclear or whatever
and sometimes they just you know file a
bug report and then quickly fix it um
uh so yes um
one of the biggest helps has been
just the constant flow of new innovation
that's coming from the company
um you know like the the wolf from what
is it called the development engine the
free development engine that you can run
on the cloud or
uh the the wolfram uh command line
interface those have been helpful
uh and basically anytime there's a new
you know stephen had a bunch of
announcements
a couple days ago things that seem like
they might be interesting to
pursue um so but beyond that no
there's i've not noticed any limitations
in the sense of
my god i really need to rewrite this in
assembly now or c or even python
that's just never happened
there have been i'll tell you one thing
in one esports application i did need to
do i
there's there was a great package in r
for fast and
fast and frugal trees which is a really
nice package very few people know about
it but it's useful to look at it's
different than machine learning but
anyway um then it's integrated within
mathematica you just plug into
our library and we just ran it directly
we have the data in mathematica so you
just call it through the external
service r
and boom you get the results right back
um
jesse is asking what kind of
infrastructure systems do you use to
integrate
with language at the back end do we use
web mathematic epc no
we as we grow we'll probably have to do
some kind of private cloud
thing but for now uh and up to many many
many thousands and tens of thousands
maybe even hundreds of thousands of
users
uh we just run it on us on servers
that um running notebooks that are live
uh with automatic
error detection and correction stuff
like that um
and it's been beautiful the nice thing
is we don't have any
we don't have any website cloud user
facing stuff that we need to run like
with the web mathematica
in the past for consulting work for like
the nba i've had to create cdfs or
otherwise create
web forms but that would just be in the
public cloud and then people could use
that as dashboards
uh but we don't have a client facing
things other than the app itself so the
um
it would be nice to have uh so i guess
this is answered to todd's and jesse's
question it would be nice
oh and john's too if it would be nice to
have
a wolfram language app builder for
mobile apps
that would be really cool to have um we
don't have that yet
john's also asking have you ever
reported a wolf language defect
that could not get a fix and had no
workaround
um yes uh i have
uh no i don't know what no workaround
means there's no direct work around you
can always rephrase your
reframe your question to answer it but
the only reason i know i remember these
is
i can constantly get emails like here's
a bug you reported two years ago it's
fixed enjoy
so they they get fixed uh even the hard
ones even like
very rare edge cases um which is
which is not something you can get from
an open source community right you can
submit it and be like look this
yeah it's on the list thanks and i've
had things where i'm waiting for
uh in other open source platforms that
we've used for various other projects
for
uh the front end for the app building
that you know it just never gets around
there's no tracking on it no one cares
and
uh in one case i i fixed one little bug
like that myself
but then it doesn't go into the main
branch so i have to constantly keep
changing it from what they do
anyway it's a it's a bit of a pain it's
it's much better in wolf language
so phil i think your um headset might
have gotten
pulled out a little bit somehow can you
hear me now
yes yes that's great that's great um
were there any more
um questions from
the audience i encourage you if you have
questions out there
to um to post them in
the the chat oh jesse has his hand up
so i think that was just applause i
actually had asked
because it's gonna feel like it was a
confusing ui thing
because it seemed like because i guess
they have the uh
um what is it like raising your hand or
something
on this thing as they try to like oh the
bravo okay
we have the subtitles here okay good
good
but i have a question for you john
before we go tell us a bit about um the
eureka program and what your plans are
for it what are your short term plans
for the next six
12 months sure so i will
actually hand that over to kevin
and i'll allow kevin to answer that
um in the next six or twelve months i
think
where you know right now we've we so we
started with like a group of people
mostly summer school people
um and we kind of went through that list
and like
looked at you know who who was
interested in entrepreneurship and we
started with them as kind of our mvp set
of like
uh uh people that we want to cater to
right
um so we started designing events around
that and we're going to keep designing
events as we kind of ramp up and we see
you know what kind of people are
interested what kind of things are they
expecting from us
you know in startup fashion we're we're
trying to design events and design the
program as we go right so we're not like
we're not saying like oh this is set in
stone you're going to have a deliverable
on xyz date
it's more like you know we'll keep
hosting events and we'll see you know
what kind of feedback did they like this
kind of event what kind of events do
they want to see in the future
and we'll just keep designing a program
around that so my honest answer is i
don't know
um that's very entrepreneurial that's
great
yeah yeah is there a is there a
community
or are you on wilfred community or
rocket chat or something that people can
join
there is there's a linkedin and i can
send you the link to that um so we are a
closed community so what that means is
that it is it is invite only so you will
have
uh you will have to apply um and once
once once you're in i can send you the
invite link to the linkedin and
and you can join on there um but so you
know as our as our guest speaker i'm
sure i can just send you a link
[Laughter]
yeah that's great i would add too that's
like kevin is someone who's been
instrumental in this and really pushed
to use like more startup methodology
in terms of um organizing
the eureka program itself and to try to
cater to the audience as people
kind of um using the initial summer
school people
and then as we open it up for people to
apply um so that we
will act like any other startup with
eureka
as opposed to having like something that
that's fixed like that and i love the
name eureka apparently it's the same
root as uh
heuristic and heretic right so
you have to be a bit of both you need to
use heuristics against your answers but
you have to be crazy right you have to
go against
yes exactly exactly speaking of that
with sports
um if we could go back a little bit to
like esports
like what do you see like
the environment for sports being like
with like live physical
sports and esports
um and as that like progresses with
technology in general and then what do
you think that means for like
swipe.bat uh so as they change we're
going to have the advantage right
because we can be flexible um i i don't
know
what the future will hold i my
understanding is
real sports viewership and interest is
kind of
down now because of this pandemic you
keep mentioning
that apparently we have um uh and
maybe it just puts things into
perspective right that
you know putting a ball in a hole it's a
game right it's not
last year you know there's a last game
the last game of the finals potentially
is tonight
right if this were last year i'd be like
wearing a jersey and running around
ripping my clothes off right but this
year it's kind of like i'll turn it on
yes yes indeed and and what do you think
for esports because it's like
you've witnessed that like well i think
many of us have witnessed that like
um we have to spend more time indoors
and yes
there are these like so we couldn't play
like we can't go to the gym and like
play basketball or for me
swim but esports are something where
it's like you can interact with
people um what do you think it means
there
like i think we're we're we're preparing
for the singularity right we're
gonna be uploading and playing esports
all the time or
clones of us or whatever um and one of
that preparations
is staying at home and playing with
people and zooming right
so i think you're right i think esports
has gone through the roof this year
because
people are home no one's really watching
you what you're doing yeah you're
working
and people are probably even more
productive by playing
six hours of video games a day than just
chatting and hanging out by the water
cooler for six hours a day right they
still get the same two hours of work
done
[Laughter]
um no in indeed and it seems like with
swipe dot bet you guys are well
positioned because you can
with wolfram language integrate new
sports rapidly as they kind of
and i think kevin you you mentioned this
before it's like
maybe kevin can you like say a little
bit more about
um esports just for people who don't
know like how
rapidly they ascend and like fall yeah
yeah sure i
i actually play some esports so no i'm
not i'm not nearly that good i'm like
what do you play
what do you play um i i i played
uh league of legends i played overwatch
like usually around like the platinum
kind of level so it's like nowhere near
serious that's
serious like if you wanted to be like an
eastwood player you have to be like top
i think it's top 500 in north america
and even then that's like nothing
compared to the koreans
honestly um but yeah no um so like
league of legends
i think was i should you know i should
say dota dota kind of started the
esports kind of scene but it didn't i
don't think it really got
huge until league of legends came around
um
and league of legends has managed to
stick around but like dota is kind of
falling out and then overwatch had like
a huge
rise in like um a year and a half and
then now it's kind of
died out from popularity so they kind of
fade in and fast
in and out or not so i was concerned um
phil i had a question for you before was
like
you know how how would you um is this do
you see this as like a risk to your
business the fact that you can build all
this stuff for like this new game that
came out
and in the next two years it just falls
out of popularity and you just got to
rebuild for a new game again
yeah that's that's that's what we're
talking about yeah that's no problem for
us but you're absolutely right it's a
major problem for us
traditional sports books or casinos
because they have to build up a huge
infrastructure and everything else
do you think that like that's another
question i have like
do you how do you think the kind of
casual
um
casual kind of um sports
gambler sports participant because i
mean it may be like what i've seen with
fantasy
sports is that like people still have
office pools for
like ncaa games and it's
huge i mean it's big enough that you
know we had presidents talking about
their office pool right like it's
accepted and everything
um but how do you see that kind of
comparing to
like your and then again this is my lack
of experience but i'm gonna go to casino
right
like you're in casino sports gambling
kind of
you know you walk up and like you you
place a bets a bet slip
type thing like what what do you see
like that happening
um and and what do you see like
swipe.bets kind of roll
like within this kind of ongoing kind of
thing between
casino type complex gambling
and fantasy sport type more casual and
then
you guys i so the first thing is that
people obviously love to bet they want
to monetize their
superior knowledge relative to other
people um the way to monetize that the
pools are great right the march madness
those are fantastic
because that's something people can
think about will this team beat that
team that's that's something you wake up
and
care about um but like the over under
all that stuff people don't care about
the sports books
wages people don't care about if you can
now talk about the people who are
watching the game
if they can monetize their information
how can they do that they their
knowledge
they see oh they're leaving lebron wide
open right he's to go off right he's
going to go
score and you can see that right how do
you monetize that there's no other way
except through swipe.bets that's what we
want to offer people
gotcha excellent so we we're coming down
to the last
two minutes here i just want to pull
again in the
audience to see if there any questions
out there um
there's a there's one very important
question for for kevin
uh from jesse do you see it yeah what's
the
i i can't even pronounce this word uh is
it domino
jesse we might
[Laughter]
is it eureka um that's a that's a good
question that's a really important
question
i wake up and i think about this
question every sunday morning
i'll have to get back to you on that but
definitely you know on the top of my
list thank you jeffy
thank you alrighty well let's wrap up
here a big
thanks to phil myman of swipe.bet
um really appreciate you
uh coming and giving this interview the
first of its type
my eureka moment number one episode
number one
number one um and hopefully we'll have
many more of these
episodes fantastic urge you uh to
to apply if you're interested in the you
will from eureka program at the bottom
of the pathable
description of this there's an
application and you can go ahead and do
that
um if you have any other questions
certainly um you can
email or connect with us on pathable
um i'm john woodard kevin howe and then
also again like much thanks to our our
guest here
founder phil meyman thank you thank you
john thank you kevin thank you everybody
have a great day everyone thank you bye